guess what I have to deal with every
morning at night now let me hey this was
per episode this episode of the genius
brain podcast I hate bringing you on let
me rip it let me let me read correct
your correction rule tell everyone that
you know that's not the truth because
let me recorrect your correction like
[Music]
her example of a sink being full is the
biggest exaggeration on earth can I tell
you one time I even have the text proof
to prove what you're saying she was like
irritated one day right she goes hey
next time before I go to work can you
make sure the house isn't a mess and she
says she sends a photo of the sink and
encounter right can I tell you what it
was the sink was filled with to the brim
with one cup and a fork inside the cup
and the counter had a pair of chopsticks
on it and that was a thing that was your
description of a full sink and a messy
house you know what that wasn't the only
case and that was probably you wear it
that was probably maybe like the tenth
time I'm like I gotta show him something
than nothing because you know what it's
all good never completely fooled no
you've been doing so much better honey
and I am so proud of you and I really am
grateful for things you know what I hate
about you the most then you try to act
like an angel on this podcast then after
this after this whole thing gets done
with the demon comes out this very poor
depiction of who you are and by the way
on this podcast at home she does not
look like you know why I dressed up like
this because you dressed up this is this
is him dressing up by the way everyone
yo can I say this though she has worn my
boxers for the past two months hey
they're very comfortable
yeah sometimes I don't have boxers I'm
like where are they and their drapes I
used the same boxer for a whole week I
don't know what you're talking about
family I fold your boxers every other
day other day every other day every
third day
the cow say every but moving in with her
was such an interesting experience I
actually never yeah I've had a couple of
girlfriends before and you know if I
dated around but I've never ever
committed to living with somebody it was
something that I was deathly scared of I
didn't I didn't really want to also make
sense with the whole toilet situation
well the toilet situation thing but I'm
just saying I'm just adding so finish
your sentence by the way you know in the
beginning of the quarantine there's so
much time I was like I'm just gonna
respond to everybody but it was so funny
because 90% of them agreed with me no
cuz they're all women and so uh exactly
the funny thing was is that I'm not
gonna even really get into it but the
dumb thing was you know when you talked
about the peace bladder thing right
there like when you peace bladder just
clean it up why do you pee on the toilet
all the time it's like it's not all the
time I mentioned on the podcast that the
pee gets on the thought that I was
peeing on the top of the seat she's
talking about when it's left up and it
splatters so because I thought to you
why do you pee all over the seat it's
like no you dumb [ __ ] it happens in the
middle of the night when the toilet seat
is up you gotta talk about it don't you
because people are dumb and I refuse to
lose it is my dick and I would tell
everybody he has done a better job and
I'm really proud of you and we figured
out our compromise too
we'll just put both the seats down yeah
it's because when we talk about this on
the podcast right we're we're kind of
rehashing old thoughts they they think
that the argument is actually something
that we've been fighting about for like
six years or some [ __ ] but it's really
the the actual argument was like a
half-day conversation and then we just
tried after that it's so funny it's
weird because when people don't have an
experience with like a long-term
relationship they go oh god you you guys
you guys need some therapy I don't need
therapy for [ __ ] I love this [ __ ] right
here just my lady right here it's my
ride-or-die and she loves this [ __ ]
right here to believe is real I feel
like we do need therapy take the time
but yes
you want couples therapy you know time
to time I think we overcome them and
like okay another another tornado has
passed by couple couples therapy for mmm
I feel I think any I think a lot of
people have the same issue it's just
sometimes we must understand each other
it's been pretty good though for the
past for a while actually it's been
pretty good mmm
cuz the tornado has passed by and we
survived you know and when something
like that big trauma comes around get
together also to shout outs to her best
friend because she's a she's right
across the street so she asleep might
have talked to the godmother for us it's
just like what we're doing and they
she'll see it from an outside
perspective if she goes yeah maybe this
maybe that yeah and she has similar
personality as you so she doesn't always
agree with which is good because
sometimes I feel like I'm crazy right
crazy I you know if anybody asks for any
proof of any crazy stuff that he said he
doesn't do I have like what it's a lot
died like this week the sick I have
proof of what you think a full sink is
it's okay anyway I know I use multiple
cups right I have this very weird habit
now of using multiple cups which I
didn't have before because you know
you've had it
hold on a second girl let me almost
costed that sick in your old apartment
it's not yeah it was not you know why it
wasn't my I can't know why it wasn't
mine because somebody else did it so I
made it a point not to do it it turns
out that when that person doesn't do it
no I'm a lot doing it so I started doing
it I did not so do you want me to do it
so that you could even ask Khalif and
Ray it was never would you like me to
start on it so that you could stop I'll
use all the cups you can use all the
cups I don't mind but it bothers you so
I don't do it and that's what you call a
good you don't say you try not to do
which I really do appreciate yeah and
you know actually that's not even the
weird part the prayer part is like you
when you have a left
her dish or a bowl you put it in the
sink and you dump water in there with
the remaining food because you don't
believe it think because if the food
dries up it sticks to the ball so you
yeah moisten it that's all you throw
away the food first not that's too much
work you just let it moist in there the
most and so okay and so I asked him
because I was thinking really hard and
trying to be the best person like maybe
there's a reason why he does this so I
asked him if he got so offended by it I
didn't get offended yes you're like why
did I'm like because you got you got mad
at me cause like I really want to know
if there's a rational reason why you add
water with the leftover food and leave
it in the sink No so this is what
actually happened ended you got so mad
cuz I was like please tell me there's no
no no this is what happened alright
correct because she wasn't satisfied
with my answer
I told her I don't know I just do it
right
mm-hm and she kept nagging me about I
didn't yes you did and I told her one of
the things I told her I don't like is
that if you are going to nag at me or
pick at something don't do it before we
go to sleep going to sleep angry and
upset is something I can't do no matter
how upset she is this bill could knock
out and so what happens is she'll say
something she'll plant some kind of evil
thought in my head I do this thing nice
she just goes why do you do that right I
go I don't know it's just something that
I do I say usually when food sticks I
try to soak it in she goes what about
wet food why does for wet food I was
like I don't know like if it was ramen
or something and I left the bowl and I
said I don't know and then you kept
being so persistent about it because you
weren't satisfied with that answer
she gave us I think you know what
happened because I clearly remember I
was like I just want to know his
rational reason I said I don't know and
so I asked to confirm because like why
do you do that and I think because it
was a night time he was already a jeté
'td no no no no that's what was thought
that I was nagging but really I was just
very curious no my dear it was not like
that at all yeah you kept on being so
persistent about it when you should
drop it after I gave you the answer
that's why I was and then I told you
what I'm asking because XY and Z so I
gave you a reason why I if it there's no
reason behind to it and why it shouldn't
why it's not beneficial to use the water
cuz it's just a waste then you're
wasting the water and then and then this
is what happened after right so she has
an innate or something if something has
to happen her way she won't let it go so
for example that she hold on that night
what happened was so the garbage can
will slightly left the jar because we
had some cardboard boxes and stuff in it
right and then she goes I can't go to
sleep